hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that a lot of you have been
requesting
since uh it happened yesterday it's from
the world cup currently
being played in russia and uh it's a
game uh well it's denmark versus chile
and matt anderson of
denmark versus pablo selena herrera of
chile both of them
grandmasters and uh matt's photo is uh
a bit younger than i i think he is now
but i couldn't find any any recent ones
so
uh you know we will have to settle for
that but it's a really wild game
and uh once i started receiving all of
your suggestions
i i didn't think it was uh the game was
this interesting and even when i saw the
final position i was still like yeah i
mean it's fine but
is it really i mean why are people
suggesting it so much
and then when i you know when you go
through all of the moves then you see
why why it's so interesting so now
without further ado let's check it out
this is the first game we'll be uh
checking out from the world cup
uh and uh well uh the first of many so
without further ado let's see what
happens uh understand with the white
pieces opens with the knight to f3 he
goes for the red
opening uh we have d5 uh striking in the
center and
now e3 e3 is not the the most popular uh
idea here usually white will go d4c for
g3
in any of the moves but e3 uh isn't
played that much but okay uh we have e3
knight to f6 and now only now c4 so
probably
in a in a way to confuse black in order
maybe
to avoid some lines so here we have c6
strengthening the center and the knight
the c3 we have e6 now
uh closing the structure uh and b3 so
here
white could also play just d4 but then
we transfer into a different line so b3
uh we have bishop to d6 and now only now
d4
we have castles in the now comes queen
to c2
so just continuing development and queen
to c2 is actually a new move here
uh some of the known moves are bishop e2
bishop d3 bishop to b2 but queen to c2
is a new move so already as of move 7 we
have a completely new game
so let's see how herrera deals with with
this idea we have knight
beat the d7 and now we basically
transpose into the
main line of the semi-slav the the
schloz variation
uh we have bishop to e2 white also is
ready to castle
b6 preparing to finca to the light
square bishop and now
uh white castles we have bishop to b7
and the bishop to b2 so both players
just putting pieces on optimal squares
and
the okay it's not a super proportional
position but it is
um you know uh it is a very similar one
queen to a7 both players now just
developed the queen connect the rooks
and now both players bring both of the
rooks into the game so rook 8 to d1
rook 8 d8 rook after e1 and rook f2 e8
and now
both sides have basically finished
development now it's time to decide what
to do here and white improves the
position with bishop to f1
so you are always a useful defender on
f1 just guarding that
g2 pawn as the bishop here is on b7 so
if the position opens up it could be
could be a very dangerous piece and also
you are now having more control with
your rook over the e file
and now comes c5 black also needs an
active move and he
he decides to bust open the position
with c5 uh if you don't do this
you can pretty much just wait and see
what happens with some like maybe h6 but
black decides to strike in the center
with c5 we have c
captures on d5 e captures on e5 and
now g3 now countering the the dark
square bishop here
and also making room to develop this
bishop to g2 we have rooked the c8
now the rook isn't doing all that much
here but the queen isn't c2 so rook here
preparing to open up the c file with a
move like c captures on d4
we have bishop to h3 now you are
x-raying my queen i'm x-raying your rook
so let's see how black
continues here c captures on d4 and now
comes
knight captures on d4 you might think
okay why not e captures on d4 this
exposes
the queen to the rook but now knight the
e4 is also very strong and now there's a
double attack on the knight could be
very annoying if the bishop comes to b4
with a triple attack
maybe maybe not allow black so much
activity
so instead we have knight captures on d4
and now bishop to b4 now piling up on
this knight we have knight
d to e2 now adding another defender here
and now comes knight the e4 knights the
e5 was also
also possible but knights the e4 is what
makes this game special
uh and now the position is really
awesome because uh both
white and black have a chance to do
something great here white uh for
example that there's only one good move
for white here and that's uh well you
you'd never guess but it's actually
queen captures an e4 it's it's a movie
you don't play ever
but i mean if you actually see what
black is trying to do then you
you know start uh are looking for for
ways out of this mess and then you maybe
find queen captures on e4
but it's uh it's a very interesting move
d captures on e4 now rook
captures on d7 the bishop on h3 guards
that and now we attack the queen
and we're going to win the bishop on b7
so queen f6 we're going to win the
bishop here
and now okay we can trade everything
here captures captures uh characters
characters and capture so everything
gets
just gets captured and now we can play
rook to d1 our rook is under attack and
then
the game just continues let's say a6 we
defend this rook and then rogue d to d7
uh and we have constant pressure along
the seventh rank even though white
black has a queen black is never winning
this position
so here after knight the four queen
captures an e4 is the best
thing to do for white but i mean who
plays who plays that white said all
right
just move your bishop it's it's a very
annoying piece he played a3 and now he
tries to make black trade everything
here on the c3 square
but of course black had something else
in mind so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this incredible attack
for black while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh you know think uh think of uh i think
it's the
gerganitza versus stal uh and where it
happened so uh
have at it
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not doing anything weird you guys always
try to do something weird
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight captures on
f2
uh pretty straightforward we just
eliminate the defender of the
of the e3 pawn and now if king captures
well then it's a problem just queen
captures an e3 king moose and d4
check the lights where bishop comes
alive and that's it there's uh
there's no defense you are getting
checkmate it doesn't matter what you
play so instead after knight captures an
f2 white said
okay you have your fun here i'm just
gonna pick up the bishop here and how do
you continue this attack well okay the
bishop is still hanging
knight captures on h3 with check we have
king to f1
and now queen captures on e3 now
threatening queen to f2 checkmate
so white uh has only one way to
not to save the game but maybe to
prolong the game and that is queen to f5
so still posing some problems the knight
is now under attack also this knight is
under attack
uh you don't really care about this one
since you know black is threatening
checkmate uh but this knight is uh under
attack so here we have
knight to f6 and now again it's a pretty
pretty interesting move because uh well
now if you go for this character queen
characters here just queen to f3 check
and now after the king moves then the
knight comes to g4 and again it's uh
it's a position you you simply can't
play there there's no way to play this
if rook to f1 then we just play queen
the e3 check
and now you have to go uh well on this
diagonal king h1 d4 check and again
there's no defending this you have to
start giving up pieces and it's going to
be checked
very soon so after knight to f6 the
knight cannot be captured so bishop the
c1
attacking black's queen and this is
where uh where the game really
really starts to kick off here black
plays knight to g4 he offers the queen
because the knights are simply too
deadly uh if the queen is captured with
bishop captures on e3 then just knight
captures on e3 is checkmate
and it's a very nice pattern to remember
uh where the knights are
apart uh like this where there are two
squares apart as you can see here
uh then they control these four squares
so this knife controls this and this and
this knight controls this and this
and of course the king is in check and
can't go anywhere this is checkmate so
after knight
to g4 white has to play something he
played rook to d3
uh attacking the black queen twice but
now black
offers the queen yet again with d4 uh
reminiscent of
hikaru's immortal queen if you remember
that game uh really an awesome one so
again uh the queen cannot be captured
doesn't matter
what you decide to capture with even
though you can capture with the bishop
now because the rook covers this square
it doesn't matter now just knight
captures an h to his checkmate
the king again has nowhere to go now
this is covered by the knights and of
course the g2 square is covered by our
good friend
the the dark square bishop so here after
d4
we have rook e to d1 creating some
breeding room for the king here so maybe
the king can now escape
but now comes a move well the move from
the thumbnail which is uh which is
simply incredible
uh since white could never capture the
queen now black
forces white to capture a queen every
move is winning here but
this one is just you know uh you know
gets the the the the gold coin shower
so here uh queen to g1 check uh black
gives up the queen
with this uh well with a forced move
there's no
no escape here you have to capture it
and the idea is now that
uh the knight will capture the rook will
have full control of the e file and the
king will not be able to touch the e
file
so knight captures and g1 was played and
now of course we
finish it in one move knight captures an
h2 and now it's checkmate because the
bishop covers g2
and the rook prevents the king from
escaping via the e square
via the e file the knight covers the f2
and of course the
this knight uh well it's just there but
it would make no difference if it wasn't
so really really an incredible game and
thank you so much for suggesting it so
many times because it took me a while to
you know okay i was like okay since
so many of you are suggesting it must be
a good one but um
you know never never think your opponent
is just trying to re-maneuver his pieces
like
when he played this knight to e4 he's
going for this f2 pawn i mean there's
there's no
uh way around that and if black saw that
the the attack was crushing if white saw
this then he
probably would have found queen captures
on e4 but if you don't know the knight
captures an f2 with
this crushing attack is coming of course
you don't look for
for such things but you know it was
there there was a moment where you could
do it and then
that moment was gone forever so a really
an impressive game
uh i think the the entire chile was
happy yesterday
when the game happened by uh by mr
herrera here
creating such a masterpiece and i think
all of you guys can agree that uh
well i i don't know if it's the greatest
queen sacrifice of
2021 so far because the white was black
was really trying to give up the queen
he was really really trying and white
could never capture it
and then you know at the right moment
black was uh you know he he just
sacrificed the queen
then white was forced to take it and
those uh you know
it's just like the some of these chess
games it's like they have poetic justice
in them and uh
uh that they're different they're
somehow different you can't really
pinpoint
what it is about them that that makes
them different but you know
they are uh but okay uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it really really
an impressive one
uh we're continuing the the coverage of
the of the world cup here so
uh you know feel free to suggest more
such games if they happen
and if you want to check out the first
game that was kind of titled the
greatest
queen sacrifice of 2021 uh do check it
out it will be the first link in the
description below so maybe you guys can
decide for yourselves uh which one
uh which one kind of takes the cake uh
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
it
i would like to thank al boyd
cruzada.com uh christopher marchetti
david kimura and the voice
kaminsky for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day